okay we have e4 on the board yet again
and looks like
i'm gonna have to try
something else
let's just go for my main
kind of opening here or let's play some
[ __ ] instead
why not
this line is not very good
let's see what he has in the story
though
basically the point of this is that i do
have the bishop here
so that means i have something to
to hope for even though i'm
i have currently no pawns in the center
and i'm in imminent danger of losing the
game
in a few moves
okay
this one i don't know
i thought queen e4 was the main line
there
am i supposed to be worried about this
maybe a little bit worried
yeah now g6 is a bit of an annoying
weakening
okay
bishop d7 i guess try and develop
now king of seven
obviously king in the center it's not
nothing new for me
okay so bishop c6 there's rookie one
and
if 27 there's knight c7 that is very
annoying
i just have to do something else
first don't vlog it though didn't really
want
to sort of let him get his pieces in to
play with
with tempo but what can i do
yeah this is a little a little annoying
okay queen d5 i think
would be thrilled if i could exchange
some stuff with camp queen and queen of
three there's
there's not quite a five
f3
okay let's just try and put some pieces
in the center
maybe i should go h5 actually
yeah i probably should go h5 in order to
prevent g4
yeah d4 this is a serious option of
course
i was not like i'm duly worried about it
queen on f f5 is reasonably placed and
g4 i do have some ideas
no this was missed of course
this was completely missed
now i'm in a lot of trouble
yeah how can i even protect my stuff
here
i have to go e4 5 but that is super ugly
queen c4 then i'm just lost
oh so bad so so bad
never planned it ever
okay
this is the definition of ugly
[Music]
i think this may have been missed by
hundred
keeps me in the game me in the game and
i think it was better for him to just
just take immediately i think
i've seen foreign
and we live to see another day possibly
okay i go with this rook so that i can
easier play [ __ ] of d8 later on
change more more pieces
don't see any tactics for him on this
and as long as there's nothing immediate
i might have serious chance to
to consolidate and thereby save the game
okay we'll just try and exchange
should be fine now this one i think i
can just take
take and go f5
and now i think this is just the drum
obviously my structure does not
necessarily inspire confidence but
can i go f4 and then f3
i think it's not a bad idea
maybe we should be fine then
okay i'll play more conservatively
now this of course ought to be a pretty
standard drone
okay
that was another
now to escape